[Music]  you got a big day Saturday yes you are  from Kentucky diehard UK fan okay and  Kentucky plays Louisville voice yes sir  okay and uh you're a face painter you  are a serious I have a photo here of you  and this is my little brother about a  year or so ago that you kick me like  season tickets and everything so I'm  gonna be getting my face paint on on  this Saturday for sure I won't be going  anywhere I'll be my house by myself and  my my couch oh it's so sad to paint your  face to be just alone in a room yeah it  is but you know I can't hold back he's  got to go for it and and and and  Jennifer Lawrence she's a she's a few of  elephants she's a Louisville fan okay so  does that you guys trash talk with each  other you know we got along on so many  things  and that was almost a crumble point in  our relationship but I'm happy to say  we're making it through it one one  session of a therapy at a time but very  good